the most difficult challenge of all all
prior administration's from President
Lyndon Johnson have tried and bitterly
failed but I was not elected to do small
things or shy away from big problems
it's been a long and very arduous
process to arrive at this moment on
Sunday I delivered to Prime Minister
Netanyahu my vision for peace prosperity
and a brighter future for Israelis and
Palestinians this vision for peace is
fundamentally different from past
proposals in the past even the most
well-intentioned plans were light on
factual details and heavy on conceptual
frameworks by contrast our plan is 80
pages and as the most detailed proposal
ever put forward by far as I have seen
throughout my long career as a dealmaker
complex problems require nuanced
fact-based remedies that is why our
proposal provides precise technical
solutions to make Israelis Palestinians
and the region safer and much more
prosperous my vision presents a win-win
opportunity for both sides a realistic
two-state solution that resolves the
risk Palestinian statehood to Israel's
security today Israel has taken a giant
step toward peace yesterday Prime
Minister Netanyahu informed me that he
is willing to endorse the vision as the
basis for direct negotiations and I will
say the general also endorsed and very
strongly with the Palestinians a
historic breakthrough and likewise we
have really a situation having to do
with a race that is taking place right
now it will end and we have the support
and it's very important to say this of
both parties and almost all people in
Israel they want peace and they want
peace badly
this is the first time Israel has
authorized the release of a conceptual
map illustrating the territorial
compromises it's willing to make for the
cause of peace and they've gone a long
way this is an unprecedented and highly
significant development mr. prime
minister thank you for having the
courage to take this bold step forward
and bebe we have a lot of powerful
people in this room a lot of the people
that can help make it work so that's
quite a thunderous applause thank you
very much thank you we will form a joint
committee with Israel to convert the
conceptual map into a more detailed and
calibrated rendering so that recognition
can be immediately achieved we will also
work to create a contiguous territory
within the future Palestinian state for
when the conditions for statehood are
met including the firm rejection of
terrorism
under this vision Jerusalem will remain
Israel's undivided very important
undivided capital
[Music]
[Music]
but that's no big deal
because I've already done that for you
right we've already done that but that's
okay it's gonna remain that way and the
United States will recognize Israeli
sovereignty over the territory that my
vision provides to be part of the State
of Israel very important and crucially
the proposed transition to a two-state
solution will present no incremental
security risk to the State of Israel
whatsoever we will not allow a return to
the days of bloodshed bus bombings
nightclub attacks and relentless terror
won't be allowed peace requires
compromise but we will never ask Israel
to compromise its security can't do
as everyone knows I have done a lot for
Israel moving the United States Embassy
to Jerusalem recognized him
recognizing the Golan Heights
and frankly perhaps most importantly
getting out of the terrible Iran nuclear
deal
there's a lot of spirit in this room
it's true you don't see it often you
don't see it often therefore it is only
reasonable that I have to do a lot for
the Palestinians or it just wouldn't be
fair now don't clap for that okay but
it's true it wouldn't be fair
I want this deal to be a great deal for
the Palestinians it has to me
today's agreement is a historic
opportunity for the Palestinians to
finally achieve an independent state of
their very own after 70 years of little
progress this could be the last
opportunity they will ever have and less
for a lot of reasons we'll never have a
team like we have right now we have a
team of people that love the United
States and they love Israel and they're
very smart and very very committed from
your ambassador David Friedman
who Jason and avi and Jared
and they're all great deal makers and
they also understand the other side and
they want the other side to do well
because that's the sign of a great deal
and they understand that and I just
appreciate all of our hard work you put
in and so many of your other friends and
of course our great Secretary of State
my Poppa
whoa
that's impressive that was very
impressive
that reporter couldn't have done too
good a job on you yesterday I think you
did a good job on her actually that's
good thank you Mike great Barry are you
running for Senate I guess the answer's
no after that they all want him to
Kansas great state they want him to but
you're doing a great job don't move the
Palestinian people have grown
distrustful
after years of unfulfilled promises so
true yet I know they are ready to escape
their tragic past and realize a great
destiny but we must break free of
yesterday's failed approaches this map
will more than double the Palestinian
territory and provide a Palestinian
capital in eastern Jerusalem where
America will proudly open an embassy
no Palestinians or Israelis will be
uprooted from their homes Israel will
work closely with a wonderful person a
wonderful man the king of Jordan to
ensure that the status quo of the Temple
Mount is preserved and strong measures
are taken to ensure that all Muslims who
wish to visit peacefully and pray at the
AL aqua mosque will be able to do so
this is a major statement this is a
major important importance and at the
same time our vision will deliver a
massive commercial investment of fifty
billion dollars into the new Palestinian
state you have many many countries that
want to partake in this and many of them
are surrounding they all want this to
happen
virtually every one of them want this to
happen and I think Bibi you know that
very well you're gonna have tremendous
support from your neighbors and beyond
your neighbors over the next 10 years if
executed well 1 million great new
Palestinian jobs will be created their
poverty rate will be cut in half and
their poverty rate is unacceptable now
and only getting worse their GDP will
double and triple and much-needed hope
joy opportunity and prosperity will
finally arrive for the Palestinian
people our vision will end the cycle of
Palestinian dependency upon charity and
foreign aid they will be doing
phenomenally all by themselves they are
very very capable people
and we will help by empowering the
Palestinians to thrive on their own
Palestinians will be able to seize the
new future with dignity self-sufficiency
and national pride to ensure a
successful Palestinian state we are
asking the Palestinians to meet the
challenges of peaceful coexistence this
includes adopting basic laws enshrining
Human Rights protecting against
financial and political corruption
stopping the malign activities of Hamas
Islamic Jihad and other enemies of peace
ending the incitement of hatred against
Israel so important and permanently
halting the financial compensation to
terrorists
and perhaps most importantly my vision
gives the Palestinians the time needed
to rise up and meet the challenges of
statehood I sent a letter today to
President Abbas I explained to him that
the territory allocated for his new
state will remain open and undeveloped
for a period of four years during this
time Palestinians can use all
appropriate deliberation to study the
deal negotiate with Israel achieve the
criteria for statehood and become a
truly independent and wonderful State
President Abbas I want you to know that
if you choose the path to peace America
and many other countries will we will be
there we will be there to help you in so
many different ways and we will be there
every step of the way we will be there
to help
in other words for the first time in
many many decades I can say it will work
it's going to work if they do this it
will work your response to this historic
opportunity will show the world to what
extent you are ready to lead the
Palestinian people to statehood the
Middle East is changing rapidly on my
first trip aboard as president I
traveled to Saudi Arabia to discuss our
shared priorities with the 54 leaders of
the Muslim and Arab countries I made
clear that all civilized nations share
the same goals stamping out extremism
creating opportunity for the region's
youth and we have to take care of the
region's youth the region's youth is
growing up with no hope we have to take
care of the region's youth and existing
in harmony with one's neighbors since
that time immense progress has been made
a growing number of nations have taken
strong stands against terrorism and
radicalization you see it thanks to the
courage of US forces the ISIS
territorial Caliphate one hundred
percent not ninety five percent not 99
or any other percent 100 percent of
their Caliphate Isis is destroyed and
it's savage leader al Baghdady
is now dead
and I want to thank we have some more
great senators and congressmen and women
here and I want to thank you all for the
tremendous help thank you very much Jim
Ted everybody's doing our leader leader
thank you mark thank you great people
and these are great people they work so
hard and they love this country the
Iranian regime is isolated and weakened
greatly we eliminated qua some Salamone
the world's top
and as you know he was with the head of
Hezbollah I don't think they were up to
anything good I don't think so he ran an
organization called Jerusalem liberation
forces and used his hatred total severe
hatred of Israel as a rallying cry to
divert attention from the incompetence
and shortcomings of his government he
falsely promoted the sinister notion
that a free Jerusalem
we must really be at war with Israel so
to have it free we have to be at war
with Israel and he said it very very
powerfully in fact it's been in this
false war that Israel really the enemies
of peace have used that they just used
it as an excuse to divide and totally
oppress the Middle East in truth
Jerusalem is liberated
Jerusalem is a safe open democratic city
that welcomes people of all faiths and
all places it is time for the Muslim
world to fix the mistake it made in 1948
when it chose to attack instead of
recognize the new State of Israel
it's time
since then the amount of needless
bloodshed and squandered opportunity so
many squandered opportunities in the
name of senseless causes is beyond
measure the Palestinians have been the
primary pawn in this regional
adventurism and it's time for this sad
chapter in history to end and quickly
end now it's never too late for
courageous leaders to set a new course
to pursue what is right to change the
future only for the better America is
prepared to work with all parties on our
vision so many other countries are
willing ready and able to work with us
I've spoken to many of them I cannot
believe the amount of support this
morning has I cannot believe it I have
been called by leaders Boris called so
many called and they're all saying
whatever we can do to help they all want
to see it happen
but America cannot care more about peace
than the stakeholders in the region
there are many Muslims who never visited
al-aksa and many Christians and Jews who
never visited the holy sites in the West
Bank described so vividly in the Bible
my vision will change that are majestic
biblical heritage we'll be able to live
breathe and flourish in modern times all
humanity should be able to enjoy the
glories of the Holy Land this part of
the world is forever connected to the
human soul and the human spirit
these ancient land should not be symbols
of conflict but eternal symbols of peace
thank you again for all of the work
you've all done and all of these
incredible honored guests for being here
and in particular I want to thank Prime
Minister Netanyahu I also want to thank
Amon Bahrain and the United Arab
Emirates for the incredible work they've
done helping us with so much and sending
their ambassadors to be with us today
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you very much thank you very much
please give our regards America's
partnerships in the region have never
been greater and our alliance with the
State of Israel has never ever been
stronger than it is today together we
can bring about a new dawn in the Middle
East and I would now again just like to
thank everybody and a very special group
of people an incredible group of people
so many have been with us on this
journey right from the beginning and
we're getting there it's they say it's
the toughest deal ever to make in
business one I have a tough deal people
would say this is tougher than the
Israelis and the Palestinians they used
it as an excuse meaning that was always
the standard actually there's nothing
tougher than this one but we have to get
it done we have an obligation to
humanity to get it done
so I would now like to introduce the
Prime Minister of Israel who's worked so
hard on this Benjamin Netanyahu thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the middle-east we drink water before
a long voyage this is an extraordinary
voyage
President Trump Donald I'm honored to be
here today along with my wife Sarah
ministerial Yves Lavigne ambassador Ron
Dermer Ron thank you for everything
you've been doing
National Security Adviser advisor mayor
Ben Shabbat thank you to mayor and our
entire delegation we are honored to be
here with you mr. president with
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo we
applaud you Mike secretary of the
Treasury Steve Minuten national security
adviser robert o'brien America's UN
Ambassador Kelly craft Jared Kushner and
Ivanka it's good to see you both
it's good to see the unfailingly
energetic and optimistic ambassador
David Friedman Jason Greenblatt Harvey
Berkowitz Brian hook and the rest of
your exceptional piece pan mr. president
it's good to be here with the other
distinguished ladies and gentlemen of
your administration with senators and
members of Congress who are Israel's
greatest friends on Capitol Hill thank
you
thank you
with the ambassadors of the United Arab
Emirates Bahrain and Oman what a
pleasure to see you here and what a sign
it portends I was going to say of the
future what a signed it pretends of the
present
[Applause]
to all of you into the many
distinguished other distinguished guests
who are here today this is a historic
day and it recalls another historic day
we remember May 14th 1948 because on
that day
President Truman became the first world
leader to recognize the State of Israel
after our first Prime Minister David
ben-gurion declared our independence
that day chartered a brilliant future
mr. president I believe that down the
decades and perhaps down the centuries
we will also remember January 28th 2020
because on this day you became the first
world leader to recognize Israel's
sovereignty over areas in Judea and
Samaria that are vital to our security
and central to our heritage
[Applause]
and on this day you too
have charted a brilliant future a
billion future for Israelis Palestinians
and the region by presenting a realistic
path to a durable peace since the moment
of its birth
Israel is yearned for peace with our
Palestinian neighbors and peace with a
broader Arab world for decades that
peace has proved elusive despite so many
well-intentioned plans one after the
other they failed why did they fail they
failed because they did not strike the
right balance between Israel's vital
security and national interests and the
Palestinians aspirations for
self-determination too many plans tried
to pressure Israel to withdraw from
vital territory like the Jordan Valley
but you mr. president
you recognized that Israel must have
sovereignty in the Jordan Valley and the
other in other strategic areas of Judea
and Samaria rather than pay easy lip
service to Israel's security and simply
shut your eyes hope for the best
you recognized that Israel must have
sovereignty in places that enable Israel
to defend itself by itself
for too long far too long the very heart
of the Land of Israel where our
patriarch sprayed our prophets preached
and our kings ruled has been
outrageously branded as illegally
occupied territory well today mr.
president you are puncturing this big
lie
you are recognizing Israel sovereignty
over all the Jewish communities in Judea
and Samaria large and small alike these
as the distinguished pastors who are
here know very well these are places
inscribed in the pages of the Bible
these are places carved into the bedrock
of our common civilization the sacred
tomb in Hebron where the fathers and
mothers of the Jewish people are buried
Bethel where Jacob dreamed of a ladder
ascending to the heavens
she law where the Ark of the Covenant
that held the Ten Commandments for 10th
century for 10th century for a sorry for
centuries that's what happened in Shiloh
thanks to you mr. president these areas
and so many others that for millennia
have been etched in the soul of the
Jewish people and inspired the
imaginations of millions of people
around the world and across the world
these areas will now be recognized by
the United States as a permanent part of
the Jewish state
[Applause]
mr. president because of this historic
recognition and because I believe your
peace plan strikes the right balance
where other plans have failed I've
agreed to negotiate peace with the
Palestinians on the basis of your peace
plan it's a great plan for Israel it's a
great plan for peace frankly mr.
president given all that you have
already done for Israel I'm not
surprised you have been the greatest
friend that Israel has ever had in the
White House
[Applause]
frankly though we've had some great
outstanding friends in these halls it's
not even close you're historic decisions
to recognize Jerusalem as Israel's
capital to recognize Israel's
sovereignty over the Golan Heights to
reaffirm Israel's legal claims in Judea
and Samaria to stand up to Iran to pull
out of that dangerous Iran deal to
confront confront is not the word to
eliminate Qasem Soleimani to support and
encourage unbelievable cooperation
between Israel and the United States in
the military and strategic and
intelligence fields all this bear
testament to the friendship and depth of
your leadership and commitment to Israel
from our very first meeting here in the
White House three years ago you
repeatedly made clear your commitment to
help Israel achieve peace with the
Palestinians and peace with the rest of
the Arab world mr. president I share
that commitment and I look forward to
working with you to achieve a peace that
will protect Israel's security provide
the Palestinians with dignity and their
own national life and improve Israel's
relations with the Arab world your peace
plan advances all these goals first it
addresses the root cause of the conflict
the incident by insisting that the
Palestinians will finally have to
recognize Israel as the Jewish state
second it stipulates that Israel will
retain security control in the entire
area west of the Jordan River thereby
giving Israel a permanent eastern border
a permanent eastern border to defend
ourselves across our longest border this
is something we've long to have we now
have such a recognized boundary third
your plan calls for Hamas to be disarmed
and for Gaza to be demilitarized fourth
it makes clear that the Palestinian
refugee problem must be solved outside
the State of Israel fifth it calls for
our ancient capital Jerusalem to remain
united under Israel's sovereignty and of
course ensures that religious sites
remain accessible to all faiths and it
maintains the status quo on the Temple
Mount
six your plan does not uproot anyone
from their homes Israelis and
Palestinians alike instead it proposes
innovative solutions whereby Israelis
will be connected to Israel and whereby
Palestinians will also be connected to
one another this is that helps if you
have these real estate people you know
they can come up with they can come up
with things normal human beings don't
think about and they have mr. president
Israel wants the Palestinians to have a
better life we want them to have a
future of national dignity prosperity
and hope your peace plan offers the
Palestinians such a future your peace
plan offers the Palestinians a pathway
to a future state I know that it may
take them a very long time to reach the
end of that path it may even
a very long time to get to the beginning
of that path but if the Palestinians are
genuinely prepared to take that path if
they are genuinely prepared to make
peace with the Jewish state and if they
agree to abide by all the conditions you
have put forward in your plan Israel
will be there Israel would be prepared
to negotiate peace right away
regardless of the Palestinian decision
Israel will preserve the path of peace
in the coming years for at least four
years Israel will maintain the status
quo in areas that your plan does not
designate as being part of Israel in the
future at the same time Israel will
apply its laws to the Jordan Valley to
all the Jewish communities in Judea and
Samaria and to other areas that your
plan designates as part of Israel in
which the United States has agreed to
recognize as part of Israel I like
this decision will protect Israel's
security ensure Israel's national
interests and leave open the possibility
of a political settlement with the
Palestinians in the coming years mr.
president I hope the Palestinians
embrace your vision of peace embrace the
plan that you and your team and us work
so hard to achieve I hope that they
seize the opportunity offered by your
sweeping economic plan I've read it it
takes enormous talent to reject 50
billion dollars worth of investment I
know what that does to an economy I know
what it will do to Palestinian lives I
know what it will do to the youth of the
region I hope that the Palestinians
embrace this and build with Israel a
future of prosperity and peace I also
hope that our other Arab neighbors
embrace your vision and forge a path of
reconciliation with Israel that can
create for all of us a brilliant future
mr. president I want to congratulate
your fantastic team there's no other
word your fantastic piece T for all
their work
Jason Greenblatt
thank you Jason for the terrific job you
did
as America's peace envoy for nearly
three years
avi Berkowitz thank you for stepping out
Thank You avi for stepping out from your
important behind the roles seen behind
the scenes role and a Blee working in
those past few months to get this plan
done ambassador David Friedman thank you
Dave thank you for your essential
contribution to this effort and for the
terrific job you do every day to
strengthen the great alliance between
Israel and America and Jared Kushner
without your wisdom your persistence
your resolve this day would have never
come
I know how much the Jewish future means
to you and to your family
well Jared today you will help secure
that future the Jews state owes you and
it owes President Trump an eternal debt
of gratitude
mr. president on that historic day of
May 14th 1948 both David ben-gurion
and President Truman's had a fateful
decision to make many argued that
ben-gurion should not declare Israel's
independence many argued that President
Truman should not recognize the Jewish
state but both leaders understood the
magnitude of the hour they seized the
moment and they changed history like you
mr. president I understand the magnitude
of this moment with you mr. president
I'm prepared to seize the moment and
change history I know that there'll be
opposition
there's always opposition I know
there'll be many obstacles along the way
much criticism but we have an old Jewish
saying if not now when and if not us who
in law shall a Matai in law an afternoon
as me mr. president your deal of the
century
is the opportunity of the century and
rest assured Israel will not miss this
opportunity mr. president Donald Israel
is blessed to have your friendship and
your powerful leadership and Israel is
blessed to have the friendship of the
greatest power and earth the United
States of America may God bless america
may God bless Israel and may God bless
us all with security prosperity and
peace thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]